всім привіт ми назвали сашка норманською
я пішов у селі придатності історії для
дітей усіх уроку
вона ви і шведу шкільної програми теж я
навіть у тиші щоб писав
сама вс чи історії тощо. кислих та
читають і вивчають їх на я мучитиму для
найменша риса чого я пропоную
влада у книжечку історії про мужика він
позову за книжку називається влада рамок
вуса обидва природи чоловіка
unesco cvs або історії про таку особу
дружно братству
мужика жнивкою мишкою та інших істориків
видавалася обживати у нас petman а ми і
на них можна налити настане і аллах він
їх навіть нас точно в салат прага донецька
і жити від усієї історії
два роти читати ці хто флеша пачіно і
цитати з намба ван і новачки та шкірки
розділ sale крему за вашому природа
краву проілюстровані як мишка сбер
як азог косці дракона об малька і повис
тим як рамка титанік мальви cvs або
каски з казка про головне доброго
любов найму повернулася за х плеча і в
салат трилогія чудово я туди ваську
тут я все видно і мирних прохід до
кумедних епізодів тут на нього вірні і
кумін не герої
таки наприклад біг директор школи
хубба-бубба ви люблять і драконів а люблять
і смішних драконів віджив amd робот штати
сарі розуму ляка маляка
принцеса дракона малюка і нав'язаний
дракон і вже навіть незабаром малюка
і гаплик куди увійшло наказ і виростала не
одне покоління теж моя каска з
подівся стануть вам на рік вашої
посмішки виправимо в них не знайдуть їх
поколінь